en er zit enorme tractie in de samenleving full
dat we 1 verandering willen van die bestuurscultuur
die jullie net beschreven hebben
en die verandering komt uit de kamer
dus dat is 1 behoorlijke verantwoordelijkheid
en daar HEB ik ook over geaarzeld
ja dat weten we
ja maar het is toch logisch
op het moment dat je terugkomt van 1 burn out
je niet de eerste dag erop denkt
dan zal ik eens 1 politieke partij oprichten
dus ik HEB daar geen en maar als ik het besluit
dan doe ik het ook
als ik besluit dat ik achter de belastingdienst aan zit
dan doe ik het ook als ik besluit
dat we dat moordonderzoek altijd doen
ook al valt de regering daar wat er gebeurde
dan doen we het onderzoek
dus wanneer dat besluit te ligt
ziet u dat ik er goed over nagedacht HEB
en niet 1 snel besluit wat later
en dat is precies hoe die bestuursroute bij ons ging
zoals bijvoorbeeld
die communicatie voor de toeslagenouders die misschien
snel besluit want kennelijk is dat goed hè
zo snel mogelijk besluiten
en er achteraf te achter komen dat er niet werkt